worry i think it's a lot of bad press
because we don't use it very well
and so when i call it worrying well it's
really about what is worry
how do we do it what's the purpose of it
is it possible
that worry has a positive function which
it does
worry basically is an adaptive function
it's some
it's something that allows us to go over
and over something in our minds
in an attempt to solve a problem or
resolve a situation so i think that
that's the adaptive you know we humans
have been born
with faculties in our brain that as far
as we know don't belong to any other
creature
on earth and it has allowed us
to you know to
[Music]
come from being a pretty vulnerable prey
animal
on the african savanna to becoming the
dominant creature
on earth it's you know we we don't have
many tools for survival if you look at a
human as an
animal you know we're pretty vulnerable
you know we don't run very fast we don't
have big teeth we don't have big claws
you know we can swim a little bit but
not very well we can't
fly very well so out there
you know without a lot of technology and
on the african savannah we are
meat basically and um
and we've got systems built into our
system that we inherited and
from the development of other prey
animals that lead to things like fight
and flight response
which are adaptive in some situations
and maladaptive in another
but one of the things that our one of
the qualities that we've developed
is or one of the mental abilities and
functions is
imagination it's i could really make a
strong case that
imagination is is one of the key things
and maybe the key mental faculty that
separates
the human from the not from all other
forms of life that imagination lets us
remember things from the past it lets us
project things into the future and think
about how things
would be in the future if you did
something this way or
that way you know and everything that
exists on earth that wasn't made by god
or nature
would ever pick take your pick or some
combination of the two everything else
that exists
everything that humankind has created
started
in somebody's imagination that's where
it made its first appearance
on earth is somebody's imagination oh we
could do that
you know we could make it round it'll
roll we could chip these you know
they notice that two rocks chipping
together makes fire and they
figured out a way to do that so
imagination
you could make a case that outside of
god or nature that the human imagination
is the most powerful force on earth
and the thing is very few of us have
ever really been taught how to use it
most of our education especially
all the way through to higher education
is on using other mental faculties which
also have made us very powerful the
ability to analyze
the ability to calculate the you know
linear logical rational scientific ways
of thinking have also contributed
to us being very powerful because they
allow us to take the things that we
imagine
and make them real in a certain way but
a lot starts in the imagination
worry is a function of imagination if
you didn't have an imagination you
wouldn't be worried
that's what lobotomies are about
and that's what a lot of that's what
certain medications are about
so we used to joke at our academy for
guided imagery you know that if we could
find a simple non-toxic way to do an
imagineectomy
we could resolve everybody's worrying
stress problems you know you would you
just wouldn't be very worried
you wouldn't do much either you wouldn't
be creative
you know you wouldn't but you wouldn't
be worried if we could do that so i
think
rather than taking the imagination out
what we want to do is learn how to use
it better
and so a lot of what i'm going to share
with you about worrying well
or worrying more effectively has to do
with how you use
your imagination so worry and stress
have a lot of overlap right and we often
use them interchangeably i'm going to
spend
a little time to differentiate these
things a little bit but they do
overlap quite a bit and then anxiety
also overlaps with worry and stress
they're all a little bit different
and they're very interrelated um
they share in a lot of different kinds
of ways
the reason this is important is because
our consciousness
and our ability to become self-conscious
is potentially the greatest tool that we
have
for improving our lives and it also
if we don't know how to use it can be
something that can make
our life miserable so i like this ashley
brilliant
you know due to circumstances beyond my
control
i am master of my fate and captain of my
soul so
like you're it if you want to do
something
about your anxiety your stress the way
that you think
the way that you create your life you
know you you are the captain whether you
whether you like it or not um so we
might as well learn how to use these
capacities because there's really no
going back
i think sometimes unconsciously we try
to go back with other ways of managing
anxiety and stress like
drinking too much or taking drugs or
medications or eating too much all the
millions of ways we have of going
unconscious
and kind of trying to just put our head
in the sand and maybe it'll go away
which it frequently does so it's
it's not that it's not a good strategy
in the short run
but as a total life plan it's kind of
lacking
okay it won't take you where you want to
go
so how are worries stress and anxiety
different so worry is a type of this is
how i think about it and i can be argued
with
i'm not sure that any of this is
absolutely true i'm
kind of throwing it out there i'm
writing a book on it so
if i'm wrong please tell me before
the book is written
but it seems to me that worry is a type
of thinking
okay it's a and our friend here ziggy
says the figments of my imagination
are out to get me that's kind of the
most common use of the imagination
is just letting your imagination kind of
go to the worst scene scenarios
getting kind of entranced or hypnotized
by
by your worries you know and
letting your imagination scare you
because i think in a sense the most
common
the most common unconscious use of the
imagination is to drive ourselves crazy
or worry ourselves sick so the bars set
pretty low
that's the good news we can learn to use
it more on purpose
and do better than that so worries a
type of thinking it's a repetitive kind
of thinking
sometimes a rumination it's generally
troubled it often has to do with things
that are either in the past or in the
future
okay it's it's the opposite of be here
now
it's the opposite of present center that
doesn't mean it's bad
and that doesn't mean that it doesn't
have a function but it's
we're in our brain we're thinking about
something we're going over and over
and over and again i think that's
because the adaptive function of worry i
always
assume that something is there is an
attempt
by by nature or by life to solve a
problem
or to give us an advantage
so if you think about what could the
advantage be of being able to go
over a problem over and over and over in
my mind well
to i think it's kind of like if you have
a big tangled ball of yarn
or or thread you know and you're you're
trying to
untangle it and you find a place that's
loose and you pull it for a while and
you get some
some looseness and then you get stuck
again so you turn the ball over and you
find another loose place and you free up
some more stuff and
you turn it over again and you free up
some more stuff and if you keep doing
that turning it over and over
looking at it from different angles
finding the loose places finding where
things are knotted together
excuse me if you persevere with it more
you know more often than not you're
going to get that whole thing untangled
and then go on to the next tangled mess
that you find
okay but you are likely to get that one
untangled and i think that's the
function of worry it lets
us it makes our it makes our concerns
transportable
you know so you can think about it at
any time and that can be
an advantage or a disadvantage
and i think that that depends on whether
you're using your brain
or or you're being run by it
your brain is an incredible organ
your mind has something to do with it
and
at least in certain circumstances your
mind can learn to use your brain
in better ways that's what this is about
so it's very easy though for this
adaptive function of problem solving and
turning things over and over
to become a habit or to become
repetitive and to become ruminative
and just kind of become its own thing
and i and i think there's a couple
reasons for that one
is that worry can
serve kind of a magical function there's
a magical
unconscious function of worry
a couple of them actually so one is that
most things that you worry about never
happen
most things that you worry about never
happen and if you you know that's an old
rubric that we've all heard
and i found myself wondering well is
that really true
so i've been teaching this as a six week
class this worrying well class i've
taught it a few times now and i've asked
people
over the at the beginning of the class
to list all the things that they find
themselves repetitively worrying about
and then sometime later on we've just
checked in with the first class which
was about nine months ago
to see how many of those things have
happened and not very many of them have
happened
so i don't know if anybody's ever
studied that really before but you could
do it yourself by writing them down and
then check in in about six months
or a year now the interesting thing
about that the way that the brain works
is
at some unconscious level of the brain
it the brain could conclude
that the thing didn't happen because you
worried about it
right that's a function of and there's
an old story
about a woman who walks around her house
she's an old woman she's walking around
her house every day
mumbling walking around her house
walking her house she walks around her
house all day long until she's
carved a rut around her house and then
goes up to about the middle of her
thighs and finally one of their
neighbors can't take it anymore
he goes over and he says you know i hope
you don't mind if i
ask you why you walk around your house
all the day
every day and she says well i'm keeping
it safe from tigers
and he says well you know we're in
indiana there aren't any tigers here
and she says see
okay so it's possible that we get
rewarded
for worrying because so many of those
things don't happen
and at some magical unconscious
primitive level of thought
those two things could possibly be
connected
the other thing that has been researched
is that in sometimes worrying about
things
distracts us from things that are
actually bothering us
so that worrying about little things and
do lists and
so on and so forth and always fussing
and always
worrying and always having something to
fuss up about and to worry about
actually distracts us from something
that might be
deeper and more emotional and uh
and actually be harder for us to take so
and and we know that that's a function
that's actually been studied so that
worry prevents
deeper richer more emotion related
emotion-laden
thinking which typically comes in images
and comes in the quiet times you know so
there's a lot
of feeling there that's hard to process
or hard to feel or that's unprocessed
and that
and that we've never dealt with it's
in a sense useful to keep the mind very
busy
because if you get quiet your emotions
will come up
and ultimately we think that that's a
good thing emotions are natural they're
healthy they have a wisdom to them
that most of us have not also been
educated in
but they can be hard to feel you know
nobody
very few people have very much trouble
feeling joy
um although a lot of times we're blocked
from feeling joy because we are
unable or unwilling to feel other
emotions
when you start feeling one emotion you
know the others go hey the door's open
and they might want to kind of come up
and be felt
so there are functions of worry and
again some of them unconscious magical
maybe not in our best interest over time
others adaptive problem solving go over
the problem so
it behooves us to kind of learn what
we're doing with the worry
and that gives us choices in terms of
what we're doing with the rest
okay so worries a thinking function
whereas anxiety
anxiety is a you know is an
uncomfortable feeling it's usually in
the chest
or the upper abdomen not always but it's
most often up in this area or this area
it's an uncomfortable feeling of fear or
apprehension
or dread dread is a it's a it's that
feeling oh my god something bad is going
to happen
i know it something bad is going to
happen you don't know
you mean it may be attached to something
or it may be free-floating and not
attached to anything
and anxiety often comes with physical
symptoms like rapid heartbeat
pain in the chest sweating you know
shortness of breath
there's often a feeling with anxiety if
anxiety is very strong like panic
attacks
there's often a very characteristic
feeling that comes with panic attacks
and the feeling is of the
is impending doom people with panic
attacks they feel
they're about to die and it's often
again since the symptoms are often in
the chest or in the abdomen
we see these things in medicine all the
time and you could you could really make
a case for
you know one of the maybe the primary
function of a primary care doctor
is seeing if there's anything else but
anxiety going on
because anxiety can cause so many
symptoms in so many systems
of the body and make us and make us
afraid
um since it's something bad's going to
happen
anxiety is a function of a part of the
brain that is a
the emotional part of the brain it's
called the limbic system or the
emotional
brain so worry belongs to the thinking
part of the brain you know and there's a
lot of interaction
but worry belongs in the thinking part
of the brain the cortex
anxiety typically comes from the limbic
or emotional part of the brain and i'll
show you what that looks like
and stress which is the third leg of our
uncomfortable
stool here is actually a physical
response
to a threat real or imagined
and um and in modern life
most of the threats are
either perceived or imagined but they're
not you know we
so somebody's probably told you the
story of the saber-tooth tiger and the
fight-or-flight response and so on you
know that this was a response we think
was
designed by nature so when you walked
out of the cave and you ran into a big
predator
like a saber-toothed tiger your part of
your nervous system
fires off and you get a big shot of
adrenaline and your heart beats faster
and you
your blood clots faster and your blood
pressure goes up and your muscles get
super charged and you're ready to run
or you know run the fastest two miles
you've ever run in your life or fight
the tiger
to death you know and then it
supercharges you it's that kind of thing
we hear about when the mother moves a
car to save the
save the baby the thing is that this
response can go
off in response to threats
that are not predators that are not it
can go off in response to
stock market movements economic
changes um thinking about aging
thinking about whether you can meet your
responsibilities
all kinds of stuff and all kinds of
stuff that is
that unless you know where the off
button is on your television
or your radio or your computer that you
can just literally
pump into your into your brain you know
24 7 if you stay up all the bad news
of every bad thing that has happened
around the world
to anybody or if it's a slow news day
what could happen okay
you know like the h1n1 flu because it's
not a terribly doesn't look like a
terribly dangerous flu right now
but it could become really dangerous
you know and that's what's got everybody
scared and everybody freaked out in
standing line what could happen
so and yes there's a balance between
again
being able to predict the future and
take measures to prevent things
happening that
don't need to happen and
freaking out for months about something
that probably will never happen it's a
yin yang kind of relationship
so stress is the important thing here is
that stress is a physical
response it's not stuff that happens to
you it's a physical response that your
body
has to survive a short-term
stress and if you survive that
short-term stress like fight like the
saber-tooth tiger you know
you've either killed it or you've run
away from it
and run the you know as fast as you can
climb the highest tree that you can you
burned up all these stress chemicals
and when the tiger goes away you kind of
limp back to the cave and
breathe a big sigh of relief and tell
everybody about how you killed the tiger
or ran away from the tiger and
and your body rested and compensated and
recharged itself and replaced all the
chemicals that it used during that
intense 20 to 30 minute fight
you know or else the tiger has eaten you
and you don't have any more
stress you know but one way or another
it's all over in about 20 or 30 minutes
okay so there's none of this like uh
years
you know of stress that go on if you're
a good worrier where
you wake up in the morning and the first
thing on your mind is
oh my god what's going to happen with
this am i going to be able to do this
and they're going to be able to meet
that and so on and so forth and of
course the really good warriors are not
only doing it during the daytime you're
up at night too
because you can't sleep right and so
it's taking your
and that takes your resilience away and
it becomes a real
you know negative vicious cycle
so to review
worry is a type of repetitive circular
thinking
anxiety is an uncomfortable feeling a
fear or dread
stress is a physical response that
prepares you to meet challenges